تحول الخط 29 الى شغل اللبنانيين الشاغل
خلال مراحل المفاوضات الاخيره
اعتبره البعض خطا حقوقيا في ما وصفته
السلطه بالخط التفوقي لتبريد خسارته لكن
الحقيقه ان السلطه تحولت استغلال هذا الخط
بالسياسه اقله هذا ما كشفته تحقيقات مطوله
اعدتها اساس ميديا في بيروت
محمد بركات مدير تحرير كان واحد من فريق
تجند لتسليط الضوء على هذا الخط الذي اثار
الكثير من الجدل
السياسي هو كان موجود لانه الدراسه
البريطانيه اللي عملت شركه
2011 عملتها بناء على طلب من الحكومه
اللبنانيه دراسه اعطتنا خط هوف و 23 و29
لبنان اختار 23 20
صار السؤال هو ليش خلق مني ايش هذا الخط
ليش اجى عني ايش بعد تقريبا ثمان سنين
تفاوض مع الرئيس بره وبين انه في قطبي
مخفيه لها علاقه بجبران بسيل ومشالعون
ليسوموا فيها مع امريكا او مع اسرائيل
بتعرف ايه البيع والشراء بالملفات اللي
فيها اسرائيل كثير مغرم
اللي صار انه عملنا مجموعه التحيات تبين
معنا فيها انه هذا الخط
اعيد الى النقاش بناءا على طلب من جبران
باسيله مشال عون كان ميشيل عون رح يمضي
على تعديل المرسوم
العشرين 20 20
بصياء التفاوض والتهديد انه بنبعثه على
الامم المتحده اللي صار انه بعد اقل من
شهر
امريكا عملت عقوبات
على محاوله اللعب بهذا الخطوط البحريه بعد
خمس ايام من العقوبات على جبران باسيل
اصدر الاصل جمهوري بيان بيقول فيه انه
المستشار اللي كان له علاقه بهذا الملف
بالاصر انطوان حداد لم يعد له اي صفه بهذا
الوقت تصعد حمله الجيش
بطريقه ذكيه بالمعنى التفاوضى ولكنها كانت
عم تاخذ لبنان على ضد اند يعني رايحين على
طريق مقفل